J'ai retrouvé dans mon atelier, un baromètre de Torricelli, du nom de son inventeur en 1644.
C'est le premier instrument qui a permis de mesurer
la pression atmosphérique
et donc de prévoir le temps qu'il va faire.
Car les phénomènes météorologiques
sont liés à la pression atmosphérique.
il s'agit d'une colonne de verre
d'1mètre de hauteur, fermée à son sommet,
avec à la base une cuve
qui contient du mercure.
Quand le temps se gâte, l'air est moins
dense : la pression sur le mercure diminue
et la colonne descend. Quand elle passe
sous la barre des 76 cm
c'est une dépression. A l'inverse, quand il
fait beau, l'air est plus dense.
La pression sur le mercure augmente
et la colonne monte.
Quand elle est au-dessus de 67 cm,
c'est un anticyclone.
Quoi qu'il en soit, beau ou pas beau, vous
connaissez la consigne : restez chez vous !
Et n'oubliez pas : nous sommes tous confinés
mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette "capsule de déconfiné"
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne pas les rater,
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...